[Music]
you haven't even started yet and before
I do so I have to do a little bit of
advertising because I was told to I work
for a company called Medano
and we're hiring and we really want some
really good data scientists we're a data
company so we're bringing artificial
intelligence into project management so
we have big ideas like bringing things
like intelligent resource management
into the future of project management's
or say can we predict when people are
taking holidays who's the first person
to replace this person and so on and so
forth we're only 2 years old and if you
were to come to work for us you would
have options well you would initially
start off on client side so right now
we're working for a major bank basically
building their data Innovation Lab and
bringing that into basically getting
them ready for the open banking era and
so I actually don't work from as much
the CEO the company is a friend of mine
this is what I do in my free time
because I don't have a life and so much
much basically it's it's a mobile
application and it allows people to meet
for the purpose of marriage now it seems
like a very big thing to say for the
purpose of marriage is like you know if
you have commitment issues this is going
to cause problems and it works in a very
similar way to tinder apparently so what
you get is you would get like a
screenshot of a person with their name
their location a little bit about them
and on top there you have a status
message what you would do then is you
would click on if you're interested you
could either just say yes I like them or
you could click on it and it will open
up and it will tell you a little bit
more about them and they would sort of
have what's called a long description
which is an explanation of or how they
decided describe themselves and now one
of the options that you have when was
March is to blur your photo and
apparently I don't have this data but
apparently 90% of women blur their
photos so if you're a man on this up
you're actually finding whether you like
this lady or not based on the other
information and not whether you think
she's pretty or not which is cool so
like I said it has been described as
tinder for Muslims and they do have
other little things in there which does
make it separate to to tinder so that
you have the option of having a willy so
will you'd be somebody like monitors how
your
talking to you I don't know anybody I've
used it you do have other things like
you would define your level of
religiosity what sex you belong to
beyond to and so on and so forth you
could view like I said you could view
further details you could then like the
person or you could cast the person that
actually is information is actually
stored you do have filter settings as
well so you can filter on age location
profession not profession age location
ethnicity marital status as in like
single divorced and old widowed whatever
and you also have the option of blurring
your photographs and once you match with
somebody that the your photo is not
automatically unblurred it's only if you
kind of circle well you're not forced as
personnel let them see what I look like
so the aim of this is project is
multifold and it wasn't just because
that was data and I wanted to play with
it and we did want to sort of identify
trends and users interactions so there's
a CEO wanted that get an idea of how
people are interacting with each other
we want you to identify differences in
behaviors between different age bands
genders and ethnicities and identify
commonalities between successful
profiles and the reason for that is well
could we then sort of make suggestions
to people world you need to write a
little bit more and you need to write a
little bit more about your hobbies what
you what you're interested in
unfortunately I didn't have who blurred
and who unblurred their photo but I was
thinking well suggesting that they
unblurred their photo might have been a
good thing as well there was other
things as well like you know when you
sort of have in this realm of
matchmaking and love and whatever you
people have come up with all these urban
legends and myths and reasons why things
aren't working so people will say oh
well you know men only want to talk to
young women and men or women only want
to talk to doctors and within the Muslim
community itself if they go I'll go in a
rural Muslim you know we're all equal
but then they have these ideas of well
will you get down to it
ethnicity comes into play so I wanted to
sort of but I wanted to see this I want
to see if it's actually true the data
actually supports whether ethnicity is a
big deal or not
spoilers I haven't been able to figure
that one out yet I just chucked
everything into [ __ ] it's an
unstructured database I have very little
experience with databases and so I can
tell you this is actually quite easy if
you're used to dealing with JSON files
if you used to dealing with dictionaries
in place and this is actually quite easy
like even the command to sort of ingest
a JSON file
straight forward I was then able to open
up [ __ ] and clear out all the users
that were inactive right so the fields
we had were we had things like GPS
derived country name GPS derived
location name the ones in in bold are
the ones I decided to use I didn't want
to use a GPS derive a country name or
location name because people move around
people go in holiday and I only had a
snapshot of the database oh I didn't
really know where they were in general I
kept age I didn't country name was just
used as a filter because this was this
is actually a global app so I decided
basically for data management purposes I
just have this little laptop I was only
only four people in the UK I looked at
their ethnic origin or how they identify
their ethnic origin their gender the
long description and I didn't look at
matches because I was you can you can
derive their anyway obviously member ID
status message who I liked who I passed
and who I viewed I removed the things
that were related to religiosity because
this was the first pass at the data and
the secretary moved because 99% of
people identified at a single sex so it
wasn't even something that was going to
be discriminatory anyway
and so the last two people didn't like
anybody and people who only who didn't
only liked inactive users made up about
2000 people so we're still dealing with
quite a large data set so we did the
first pass at the data we found these
basic things so the ratio of men to
women was about two to one so you have
twice as many men as you have women so
again this is in the UK the the ethnic
kid so you have over half of people
identifies Pakistani and then it goes
Bangladeshi other and now other isn't
mixed-race with mixed races in there
you've got Indian you've got Arab and
then I can tell you like these ones here
one of them says Iraqi so I'm not really
sure why we have Arab and then Iraqi a
separate ethnicities and there another
interesting thing that again I wasn't
able to answer in this one is that well
the majority of Muslims in the UK in the
world are Indian so how can the majority
of users are Pakistanis I don't know and
I mean look at the the distribution of
Ages of being yeah not very politically
correct red and pink would refer to
women and blue over certain men in this
talk so this is the age distribution
you'll see initially the majority so a
lot of men kind of took in the in a very
young age group so this is between 18
and 20 the youngest is 18 nothing look
like young versus 80s is between the
ages of 20 and 25 you do have more men
than women in that group they kind of
even out to the majority of users are in
the late 20s and then you need to get a
bit older the ratio of women to men
actually increases I then how to look at
how many people people like and so we
found that men so this is a logarithm so
- so this basically means this is kind
of a frequency count of the number of
people who liked 100 people so you'll
find that the maximum number of women
that men light is about 13,000 so there
is a guy on there that has liked about
14,000 women the aspect only two years
old
I don't know how I honestly I mean I
mean just physically how do you do that
unless there's a boss that you can write
that can go in and do that I don't know
I don't have that capability there is a
woman or a couple of women in there who
have liked about 7,000 men and
the average number of women that men
like is about a thousand and the average
number of men women like is about one
hundred and ninety four and so if you
look at the median and you should look
at the the standard deviation you find
that men on average like between thirty
nine twenty fifty one women and then
women like between six and thirty nine
men so it's quite a difference so if
you're familiar with OkCupid the guy
that works at the data scientist wrote a
book cutting called detective him and
like a bunch of blog post on this and
one thing he looked at was well what is
the correlation of ages between sort of
what ages are women interested in and
what ages are men interested in and does
that actually change over time so as
they get older what you see here so you
take thirty you'll see that this is the
female age so a woman in her women in
their thirties have liked men between
the ages of 20 and say 42 the size of
the blob shows the frequency so even
though she might have liked somebody in
their foot they might some women have
like men in their 40s majority of them
seem to have liked men in this case and
then I did a very simple linear
regression like linear fit when I found
that on average - the slope is about 0.5
the older women get the older them and
they like it this is the plot for the
men obviously the ball is bigger because
there's more men on there and they're
actually more active and you'll notice
that even not like as the woman gets
orders these dots sort of in the young
age groups I kind of get smaller and
smaller or in sparser this isn't the
case in terms of men to get men in their
40s who are still quite actively and
liking women in there very early 20s not
this is not one or two dots this is like
a large number of men in these age
groups or sort of liking that and the
slope here is about 0.02 so there isn't
much increase in it in the female age as
the men men get older unfortunately
going to have the profession details I
couldn't actually tell any the other
things that are sort of the other urban
legend or myth I then looked at the
number of days people were active and so
I thought you find
that the majority of people have only
been active for about 100 days you do
have people who have been on there from
the very beginning that the app has
started and this shows you this is in
general like and then I looked at the
number of people that people liked again
in general over the course of time and
you'll find that yeah the majority
people liked less than 200 people trying
to find a correlation between how long
people run there and how active they
were on the app now I then looked at
impression which is how many people saw
your profile now remember there are
still two settings on here so just
because you're on the app doesn't mean
that somebody is actually going to see
you because you not not might not match
their filter settings so what you do I
don't actually have that data directly
there so what I did instead was I looked
at the number of likes a person got and
it elected them the passes they got so
that shows you how many people saw you
and or gives you a rough idea of how
many people saw you and so we would have
a look you see that in the case of women
that the majority of them have been have
a kind of high impression under the age
of 30 and for the men they kind of have
a high impression between the ages of 30
and 40 that kind of shows people's
preferences even though I didn't have
that data directly and this is something
that I will then use to identify
something called popularity now as I
mentioned in the beginning of the talk
you can either like somebody directly or
you can have a look at their profile
first and have a think about whether you
really like them or not so I decided
that a really liking somebody might you
actually made the effort of reading
their profile as well so I defined the
real likes as the intersection of user
IDs of people that had been liked and
people who had been to people you liked
and people who you had viewed and then
defined the popularity as a number of
real likes you got this divided by the
MU the impression that you make so if
somebody saw your profile how likely are
they to like you and I found that so
basically a popularity of 85 in this
case would mean that 85 percent of
people who viewed your profile would
have liked you and before I show you
sort of the popularity and that this is
what it looks like when we plot the
likes and the real likes
the blue dots heap sorry the crosses
show you a D real like so this is the
intersection on number of times you view
to profile and the number of times
you've liked somebody and the blogs are
the number of times you've actually
liked a person so as you can see if you
have a likely for less than two thousand
likes the number of times you like
somebody in a number of time you
actually make the effort of looking at
the profile or pretty similar obviously
when you get to a silly numbers of you
know huge numbers of likes you will find
that obviously people don't actually
make the effort of looking at about
2,000 profiles so I think yeah and most
people are just going yes yes yes yes
yes maybe because they're right-handed I
don't know in a row it's meant to click
the ticket on the right hand of the
screen so then we look at the really
fine popularity and so these are this is
a popularity which is a number of real
likes divided by the number of times
somebody has seen you and then I just to
do his little histogram of that so again
the red is the women and the blue is the
men so remember if you have a score of
85 85 percent of people that saw your
profile liked you you can see a massive
difference between the behavior of men
and women here so you find that mass
majority of women if their profile gets
seen 87 percent of the time it'll get
liked if you're a man that's 10 percent
yeah what are the urban legend sort of
when you do these early sort of you know
going to singles events and stuff is
obviously then men are very picky don't
not it's women who are so then obviously
in a question what makes a person
popular what what's what separates the
people that are getting over 90 percent
of likes from those who are getting in
the lower band now for women um you just
have to have another profile and I mean
then at least you will get sixty percent
so 60 percent of people are going to
view your profile are going to like you
so I defined an unpopular profile for
women as having a popularity score of
less than 60 whereas from when I defined
as being less than 20 and in both cases
you would be super popular if you've got
a score of more than 90 so thought maybe
maybe their group
in two ages maybe you know your you're
popular if you're young know so you find
that the average age for women is in
their late 20s so it's not 23 like
OkCupid found I then I looked at the
number of words are used to describe
themselves and you find that in the long
description again there's very little
difference do you find that the popular
women in the pop sorry women's were
scoring greater than 19 those scoring
less than 60 are using the same
practically the same number of words and
describing themselves in both so a long
description and their status message and
for the men I would say there is a clear
difference if you are getting more than
90 likes or if your popularity is
greater than 90 you're actually using
significantly fewer words again this is
counterintuitive but and then the Status
Messages are all pretty much the same
the other interesting thing is that
women who are scoring up the popular
people with scores higher than 90 tend
to like fewer people than people who are
scoring in the lower cases the women who
like less than 60 people have actually
liked about 300 men whereas men who are
scoring less than 20 of light about
2,000 women the only difference that I
can find is it but there's nothing else
sort of it in in the description of the
person themselves so I decided to do a
random forest because I can't be
bothered to go through all the different
features and sort of steam oil does this
make them more likely to be popular or
not so I've been the ages I've been the
number of people that they liked
I took the lengths of the long
description and I've been that I took
the status message lengths from a bin
that I did a bit of tf-idf in a bit of
NLP now in this case I basically I
grounded the words so I create a little
function by the way there's a Python
notebook that you can have a look at if
you ever want to so what you do here is
you take you split the words and then
you then find how many words you then
try to find the synonym of each word so
I've interested in content not
necessarily the exact word that they
were using so if there were using words
like hello and hi and higher I wanted to
sort of ground them all the word hello
and I then went through tf-idf
vectorizer to the standard Python thing
but I chose features
so the status message I took the top 50
features for the top 50 the words with
the highest tf-idf score and then I took
the top 100 features do I need to
explain tf-idf to this I don't think I
do right yeah you've heard a lot about
it this this is why I'm not going to my
Python note because I think you've had a
lot of that and you're at this talk if
you want a bit of intellectual break and
I've entered 100 features in the long
description as well and it basically did
a bit of a one hot encoding and that's
how you got those features in there I
then looked at the ethnicity and the
number of days active on the app I did a
shove this through a random forest did a
bit of cross validation and I found that
the likelihood of you having a popular
profile or me being able to identify
whether you have a popular profile or
not is 50% so it's like as good as
getting so basically using this method I
wasn't able to find anything different
between the profiles so why are some
people having high scores and other
people having low scores and so I turned
to graph theory and so the question is
at least can I can I answer the question
do birds of a feather flock together and
ignore the other little birds so
initially I tried to use neo4j a pioneer
was get really nice little library for
Python and I crashed my laptop several
time I then got an account with
digitalocean and try to get neo4j
working on there and it refused it
crashed that as well so I just went to
Network X an actual fact Network X is
really easy to use I was surprised
I created an undirected graph in the
network and the reason you have to do an
undirected graph in the network so you
can use their Python array there in
their community detection algorithms and
I filtered out people who had liked over
300 people this is not actually a very
intelligent way of doing it I actually
wanted to keep everybody in there but
even there and I got like seven million
connections or edges in the graph when I
did this and there are people in there
that like over ten thousand people so
that would have actually created a
massive graph that the laptop couldn't
handle and I found that 300 was it was
enough that was basically the number of
keep the number of nodes or the number
of
Edge's per person but it could handle
then use something called louvain
modularity to find the communities now
when you think of communities within in
grass you think of this graph that's all
well connected and you find like - you
can actually identify sub graph by
randomly removing nodes and once if you
remove a node and a graph sort of
becomes disconnected you can actually
identify that as a graph so it adds it
as a community which actually works well
for sparse graphs but this is actually
very highly it's a very dense graph and
that would have taken forever and I
think in the end you would have just
found a community is just like one node
or two nodes so Louvain modularity does
something a bit I want to explain it
because I have now she done the math I
just understand it as kind of like a
density thing so it calculates the
density of nodes and it finds like size
of smallest community which has a high
density with respect to to with respect
to the density of the graph itself and
then it identifies communities that way
and it's basically marketed as as a way
of actually finding communities within a
very dense graph so I did that and I
it's actually quite a neat way of doing
it I'm actually bit quite proud of this
bit ok I've noticed at some time so I'll
show you that I've actually done stuff
and not just made these numbers up yeah
I've got quite a notebook and so
it's a very messy pison notebook I do
have it on github and you know if you're
lucky I might tidy it up before you guys
have to look at it but I doubt it so you
can just cut through it so it's a grass
stuff so here's the graph stuff it's
really easy so this is where I did the
director grass and that's because I
wanted to identify who cast me if you
remember that wasn't actually in the
initial JSON dunk and so what you do is
you just initiate a graph in this case
is a digraph directed graph you read in
the CSV file so I just basically created
a CSV file of every two nodes that were
connected and I don't know why I have
I'm running a dog toys but and then you
literally just add them it's actually
very very fast and why was i showing you
this
so I wanted to show you the Python yeah
so it is really really easy to add that
in and to create a little network graph
and this is literally all you have to do
to identify the communities you just use
the community library which comes with
the network X package and you might have
to install that separately I can't
remember but I think it might be like
comma standard now and you use something
called best partition and that actually
identifies the the optimum number of sub
graphs within the graph itself and you
can actually identify the number of sub
graphs that you want to look at and that
will it will identify what you know it's
all part of that and and then all you do
is once you have the communities you can
actually find how many you can then find
who is in which community and you can do
some little analysis on that my mouse is
a bit anyway
so identifies seven communities we
wanted to look at well so each community
had between a thousand and four thousand
members each then you had a look at how
what each community looks like again
pink is is plaintiffs women bluest for
men i lucky imagination you find that
again so to be considered popular so in
so your popularity is high if you have
more than eighty seven eighty seven
light if your score is about eighty-five
if you're a woman and it's about
fourteen if you're a man you'll find
that that is pretty much standard across
all the communities the ages again
there's their standards community for
seems to be the older community so the
average age were amended about forty one
the same two women and then you have
community six which is kind of a younger
age group so women are about twenty
three men are about twenty four but the
others are all pretty much standard the
length of the status message is pretty
much the same across all the communities
as is the length of the long description
across communities I mean you find the
top two communities and men are using
more words than average than the other
two four but again it's not significant
it's not a massive difference and I then
what I did so we had actually already
filtered the stir the Status Messages
and we'd filtered the the long
description based on our tf-idf
vectorizer and I did a bit of a count
vectorizer on that as well I wanted to
see if some communities were using
different words to do other communities
so 6f means that community six the women
in community six and then if you look at
the men in community six they're kind of
using similar words they're looking and
love are pretty important but then
that's pretty much the same for
community three the only difference is a
community three the men might be yet the
same words again so I mean like as in
having a high frequency so I again I
didn't find any difference in in the
communities in that place so I don't
think I can let this go I think I'm
going to keep going at it until I go
crazy and again my NLP was quite basic I
was only looking at phrases I might want
to
take this a bit further and start to
look at you know by ground trigrams
whatever maybe I don't know if I will do
that I also want to look at the quality
of the language so right now I'm not
actually even though I'm using a
dictionary to find the synonyms I'm not
actually capturing how much of the work
that they're using is actually well
spelled or real words or whatever so I
might want to capture that as well and
for the next one C that might be
something that might be different I also
want to look at the date that they're
active so sometimes simply being active
at a certain time in the year would mean
that your people are more likely to view
your profile and therefore more likely
to to like you looking at things like
GPS location but I would need like
several snapshots to identify where the
person usually is and also get data on
on profession and educational level and
think that's it I the the notebook and
the various different Python modules are
upon the on my github repository the
Python notebooks still a bit of a mess
but you if you want to sort of have a
look at how I did the network X graph
and do the community detection and how I
did the the machine learning random
forests off you might want to have a
look at that and I will probably be
adding a readme file in the future so
thank you for your time and if you have
any questions or feedback that would be
really awesome like you have any insight
or what else I might be what else I
could do what I'm doing wrong that would
be awesome thank you yep video
so you use both you actually have to
look at how they're connected so
basically what you're doing is it's easy
for me to imagine using the the the the
the betweenness centrality to decide in
the communities what you do is you cut
off edges until finally you have a
standalone sub graph and then that will
tell you that the community and
so no this is the number of nodes so in
total the number of people live in the
UK was about 20,000 once I cut off a
number of likes at about 300 that went
down to about 10,000 so I had 10,000
nose and some of them have about three
hundred nodes coming out of them so
you're looking at about a few million
edges in there
it was quite reasonable yes and in this
case building the directed graph is
slower building the undirected graph is
quite fast and yes as long as you're not
running anything else the partition
community detector seems to be within
minutes it will run with quite a large
graph any yeah yeah that's a brilliant
question I didn't think of it and one of
the issues I have with the officially
inactive profiles are the what I don't
have any detail data on them I just
literally have their member ID and the
fact that they're inactive but
definitely I will be using that if if I
do continue with this so this is my
hobby I'm not sure I don't get paid for
this but no I like that thanks
and am i did actually so the only thing
I've done here that I've not read about
well I've done the machine learning
stuff and the network analysis which I
haven't seen before but the things I
sort of looking at the correlation of
ages and stuff I actually got from a
defeatism book and I got some of the
inspiration from there as well the thing
okay the thing that sort of would
separate this from like a standard from
like a majority that not that the
majority would use is things like prayer
level practicing level of practicing and
things like that which I actually didn't
include in the end and that might be
something I want to look at in the
future and also if I was then to look at
the data they were acted in sorted to
find correlations with with public
holidays or major events I would not be
looking at things like Christmas and
Valentine's I would be looking like more
like servantis holiday within Islam as
well so forget so good questions Thanks
I did I did put in the s50 piece and I
was looking at the community there is no
didn't put it up service because they
were all the same so you had the same
spread of ethnicities across there was
one thing that I did find so when it
came to looking at the number of
ethnicities in the popular and unpopular
receptive of men and they were liking
there was no difference whereas with the
women they were kind of they there was a
difference as in unpopular men there
were certain ethnicities in there that
were not present in the popular woman
but I didn't take that very serious I
wasn't sure whether to read into that or
not because we do have a very big bias
towards particularly ethnicity as been
in the data itself so I hadn't actually
figured out how to how to deal with that
yet yeah
first thing is any research on the
making your picture funny because that
seems to be very efficiently keeping the
business its plot xkcd all right yes I
thought you meant mine okay partner
seems kind of nice to spend time
figuring out what the person's like
again that's a thing in this particular
data set I didn't actually know who had
their photos blurry who didn't which is
unfortunate because I think that would
have been quite important and also you
would also in the in the full database
you'd also actually capture when they
decided to make that picture visible or
not which unfortunate again I didn't
have that data this is more kind of like
hindsight for keeping it
stuff we have learned when a potato but
typically you would analyze this as you
can make a decision with your app so for
example hey we're going to make that
better now because we just learned this
one fact exactly that's also kind of
tricky because you're actually so this
is a very personal data exactly yeah and
so one of the things that we want to
sort of make a recommendation on and how
to improve again that's why I was so
focused instead of doing the the text
analysis because you can't do anything
about your ethnicity or age what you do
whatever those do who cares but you can
make an effort with sort of what you
write so if you make an assay I was
hoping that I was going to say well look
if you make an effort and actually write
a proper description you are going to
have more meaningful conversations with
people you are more likely to meet
people unfortunately I found actually a
lot of people were using will have been
quite verbose and in a long description
in their status messages so I wasn't
able to find out that was kind of where
I was going with that in terms of
actually you just use me and you think
or something the fact that women have
most of the women have their pictures
blood might explain why men are so
prolific in liking people because if you
make it a match it is likely that then
that photo would then be revealed and
then you can make a decision so actually
looking at the looking at viewing the
fruit yeah so it's not it could be that
it's not a genuine like it is is like
well I still want to make that decision
so yeah
yes sir the chat service is well you
know that question yes that's something
I wanted to do I didn't want access to
the actual what they were saying but if
it could be run remotely and sort of
tell me well how many messages are being
exchanged how long before they exchange
numbers it's very easy detect whether a
phone number has been exchanged or a
Skype handle has been exchanged but then
again that would be next situation but
yeah yeah so actually they they do have
a way of doing that so if somebody's
sort of being inappropriate you can
actually you would report them oh yeah
that's true
oh so it's not so you actually still
have so the person still has to reveal
their photograph actively it's not like
if you much of somebody do a picture
yeah so good people so have a lot of
control over their their image I guess
yeah but that kind of data is really
really personal I'm not even sure that I
would be comfortable having yeah yes
that probably they'll be okay
so we'll sing this list with OkCupid the
gyda as she wrote it was the data
scientist there and here they actually
ran experiments on their users which was
so they did things like for a day they
would remove all photographs and see how
people interacted and another day would
they would remove all text to see how
still interacted and they also had
access to all the yes they had access to
the conversations and stuff like that
those those conclusions were quite
useless I would say because they say
okay
women like doctors men like 23 year olds
okay that's it the insight wasn't as as
useful there was another one that was
done by another another dating app and
that's when they actually looked into
into the conversations that we were
having and they found that the people
that were having the long conversations
were the ones that were genuinely and
successful if you define success in this
case as actually finding your life
partners so which was actually because
again they did they found the same thing
there was no difference in ages in a
level of attractiveness in anything the
only difference between people who are
genuinely successful and those who were
not was they spent more time talking
which is actually quite nice to know the
depressing plopper
yes so this is not this is kind of this
is the OSes bend so this is between 95
and 100 so you do have people there who
do have a score of 100 everybody that
saw the profile liked them this is what
I I don't know this would be interesting
I don't know how you would do it I mean
I'm not a I'm not a developer or a
programmer or a hacker so if it's
possible I guess yes at least one of the
many times you you can identify this
kind of nation because their behavior is
inconsistent with the yes so they don't
know but I mean like the I know I said
somebody like 13,000 it wasn't a single
person there were a few people that were
sort of at the tail end almost working
they did get filtered out what I did the
machine learning and the community
detection
yeah it is but in that case why would
the men while if that was a that was a
created by the company you would find
that the number of outliers for men and
women were same whereas there's
significantly different so he got 14,000
likes for the men 7000 for the women and
the outliers thank you
[Applause]
[Music]